Speaker 1: Let's go next to Harry from
Columbus, Ohio. Harry, welcome. Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Thanks for taking my call.
Now, you don't think that Joe Biden will
run for president in 2024? Is that correct?
Speaker 1: That's that's it's just my guess.
Yeah. I mean, it's not like a prediction.
I just don't think he's going to run. No.
Speaker 2: Okay. Split 5050. You think it's
more likely he will not run, then he will run?
Speaker 1: Yeah, if you just
give me even odds, right? I mean,
I'm just saying I take the he doesn't run side.
Speaker 2: Can you briefly explain the reasons why
you think that is? I know that you've said that
Kamala Harris had to walk back a statement where
she said, oh, we're going to run calmly, you know,
kind of walk it back. Kamala Sorry about that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's why I was having to run.
Here's my word. Here's where I get that. Okay. I
just zoom out a little bit. Joe Biden's almost
80 years old or is he 80 even? I don't remember
anyway. He's he's close to 80 or 80. And I
don't know that he ever really intended to
be president for eight years. From the get go,
Jen Psaki would say. Joe Biden intends to run,
which I know is not a smoking gun in and of
itself, but it was very, very careful language.
The one time someone went beyond that, when Kamala
said, He's running and I'm his running mate,
within 24 hours, she walked it back. So I have to
imagine there's some meaning to walking it back.
And quite frankly, with the record low approval
dating all the way back to 1946, it's not clear
he'd win. I just don't know that 80 year old Joe
Biden, with a 37% approval, is going to say What I
want to do right now is start another presidential
campaign two years from now. It's just, you know,
different reasonable people can disagree.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree. And I think I'm
not so convinced that he's not going to run. I
don't think there's enough evidence. But I do see
your point. Now, I just want to get into the more
substantive part of it is. Do you think that is
why we know his approval is at its lowest level
or since you said since before he essentially
said, yes, but presidential incumbency, when rates
are, I think, 66%. I think we've had 30 presidents
run for reelection in 21. Yeah. So I just don't
know if it's wise to have somebody new and fresh.
I mean, I know it's good content for yourself to
talk about potential candidates. I'm just worried
about what will happen if we bring in a limousine
liberal like Gavin Newsom. Yeah, I'm I'm very
scared of somebody who isn't Joe Biden. Frankly.
Speaker 1: I think it's potentially scary either
way. I mean, when I think about Biden versus
Trump, Biden is the incumbent and Trump hasn't
even announced. And those polls are basically
5050 already. So if it's Biden, Trump, again,
I'm not confident Biden wins. If it's the Santos
Biden, I do think DeSantis being higher energy and
younger will confer somewhat of an advantage. And
I also don't think that that looks particularly
good for Biden either. So I get what you're
saying. The power of incumbency is significant.
We also may be in a new political era where
we're incumbency is less powerful. I mean,
Trump just lost and he was a one term president
seeking reelection. So I don't know about that.
I think you're making all valid points, but I
think there's also another story to be told.
Speaker 2: I agree. Thanks for going over
all that. I appreciate it. Have a great.
Speaker 1: Day. My pleasure. Thank you. That's a
that's a powerful phone call. Very, very strong.